Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Dr. Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
Today I am so excited to show you this.
Look.
We are going to have an AI look at 650 million
images on the internet, and then, ask it to
generate the craziest synthetic images I have
ever seen.
And wait, it gets better, we will also see
what this AI thinks it looks like.
Spoiler alert - it appears to be cuddly.
You'll see.
So what is all this about?
Well, in June 2020, OpenAI created GPT-3,
a magical AI that could finish your sentences,
and among many incredible examples, it could
generate website layouts from a written description.
This opened the door for a ton of cool applications,
but, note that all of these applications are
built on understanding text.
However, no one said that these neural networks
can only deal with text information.
And sure enough, a few months later, scientists
at OpenAI thought that if we can complete
text sentences, why not try to complete images
too?
And thus, Image-GPT was born.
The problem statement was simple: we give
it an incomplete image, and we ask the AI
to fill in the missing pixels.
If we gave it this image, it understood that
these birds are likely standing on something.
And it even has several ideas as to what that
might be!
Look, a branch, a stone, or they can even
stand in the water, and, amazingly, even their
mirror images are created by the AI.
But then, scientists at OpenAI thought, why
not have the user write a text description,
and get them a really well done image of exactly
that.
That sounds cool, and it gets even cooler
the crazier the ideas we give to it.
The name of this technique is a mix of Salvador
Dalí and Pixar’s Wall-e.
So please meet Dall-e.
This could do a ton.
For instance, this understands styles and
rendering techniques.
Being a computer graphics person, I am so
happy to see that it learned the concept of
low polygon count rendering, isometric views,
clay objects, and we can even add an X-ray
view to the Owl.
Kind of.
And now, just a year later, would you look
at that!
Oh wow.
Here is Dall-e 2!
Oh my, I cannot tell you how excited I am
to have a closer look at the results.
Let's dive in together!
So what can it do?
Well, that’s not the right question.
By the end of this video, I bet you will think
that the more appropriate question would be
“what can’t it do”?
This one can take descriptions that are so
specific, I would say that perhaps even a
good human artist might have trouble with.
Now, hold on to your papers, and have a look
at 10 of my favorite examples.
1.
“A panda mad scientist mixing sparkling
chemicals”.
Wow, look at that!
This is something else.
It even has sunglasses for extra street cred,
and the reflections of the questionable substance
it is researching are also present on its
sunglasses.
A+.
But the mad science doesn’t stop there.
2.
“Teddy bears mixing sparkling chemicals
as mad scientists”.
But at this point, we already know that doing
this would be too easy for the AI.
Let’s do it in multiple styles.
First, steampunk, second, 1990s Saturday morning
cartoon, and third digital art.
It can pull off all of these.
3.
Now, about variants.
Give me "A teddybear on a skateboard in Times
Square."
Now, this is interesting for multiple reasons.
For instance, you see that it can generate
a ton of variants.
That is fantastic.
As a light transport researcher, I cannot
resist mentioning how nice of a depth of field
effect it is able to make, and, would you
look at that!
It also knows about highly sought-after signature
effect of the lights blurred into these beautiful
balls in the background.
The AI understands these bokeh balls and the
fact that it can harness this kind of knowledge
is absolutely amazing.
4.
And if you think that is too specific, you
have seen nothing yet.
Check this out!
“An expressive oil painting of a basketball
player dunking, depicted as an explosion of
a nebula”.
I love it.
It also has a nice Space Jam quality to it.
Well done, little AI.
So good!
5.
You know what?
I want even more specific, and even more ridiculous
images.
“a propaganda poster depicting a cat dressed
as french emperor napoleon holding a piece
of cheese”.
Now that is way too specific.
Nobody can pull that off…there is no way
that…wow!
I think we have a winner here.
When the next election is coming up, you know
what to do.
6.
And still, once again, believe it or not,
you have seen nothing yet.
Yes, that’s right!
We can even get more specific.
So much so that we can even edit an image
that is already done.
For instance, if we feel that this image is
missing a flamingo, we can request that it
is placed there, but, we can even specify
the location for it.
And, even the reflections are created for
it, and they are absolutely beautiful.
Now note that I think that if there are reflections
here, then, perhaps there should have been
reflections here too.
A perfect test for one more paper down the
line, when Dall-e 3 arrives.
Make sure to subscribe and hit the bell icon,
you really don’t want to miss it.
7.
This one puts up a clinic in understanding
the world around us.
This image is missing something.
Missing what?
Well, of course, corgis.
And, I cannot believe this.
If we specify the painting as the location,
it will not only have a painterly style, but
one that already matches the painting on the
wall.
This is true for the other painting too.
This is incredible.
I absolutely love it.
And, last test, does it?
Yes it does!
If we are outside of the painting at the photo
part, this good boy becomes photorealistic.
Requesting variants is also a possibility
here, so, what do you think?
Which is the best boy?
Let me know in the comments below!
And, number 8.
If we can place any object anywhere, this
is an excellent tool to perform interior design.
We can put a couch wherever we please, and
I am really looking forward to inspecting
the reflections here.
Oh yes.
This is very difficult to compute - this is
not a matte, diffuse object, and not even
a mirror-like specular surface, but a glossy
reflection that is somewhere inbetween.
But it gets worse, this is a textured object,
which also has to be taken into consideration,
and proper shadows also have to be generated
in a difficult situation where light comes
from a ton of different directions.
This is a nightmare, and the results are not
perfect, but my goodness, if this is not an
AI that has a proper understanding of the
world around us, I don’t know what is.
Absolutely incredible progress in just one
year.
I cannot believe my eyes.
You know what?
Number 9.
Actually, let’s look at how much it has
improved since Dall-e 1 side by side.
Now there is no contest here.
Dall-e 2 is on a completely different level
from its first iteration.
This is so much better, and once again, such
improvement in just a year.
What a time to be alive!
And, what do you think Dall-e 3, if it appears,
will be capable of?
What would you use this, or Dall-e 3 for?
Please let me know in the comments below,
I’d love to know what you think.
Now, of course, not even Dall-e 2 is perfect.
Look at that.
Number 10.
Inspect the pictures and tell me, what do
you think the prompt for this must have been?
What do you think?
Not easy, right?
Let me know your tips in the comments below.
Well, it was “A sign that says deep learning”.
Well, A+ for effort, little AI, but this is
certainly one of the failure cases.
And, you know what, I cannot resist.
+1.
If you have been holding on to your papers,
now, squeeze that paper at least as hard as
these scholars are squeezing their papers.
So, which one are you?
Which one resembles your reaction to this
paper the best?
Let me know in the comments below.
And, yes, as promised, here is what it thinks
of itself.
It is very soft and cuddly.
Or at least, it wants us to think that it
is so.
Food for thought!
And, if you speak robot and have any idea
what this writing could mean, make sure to
let me know below.
And one more thing.
We noted that this AI was trained on 650 million
images, and uses 3.5 billion parameters.
These are not rookie numbers by any stretch
of the imagination.
However, I am hoping that with this, there
will be a chance that other, independent groups
will also be able to train and use their own
Dall-E 2.
Just in the last few years, OpenAI has already
given us legendary papers, for instance, an
AI that can play hide and seek, solve math
tests, or play a game called DOTA 2 on a world
champion level.
Given these, I hereby appoint Dall-E into
the pantheon of these legendary works.
And I have to say, I am super excited to see
what they come up with next.
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!